the other gossip I heard was that
Wolfie's dying his hair more than one
person in office thinks uh Wolfie is
dying his hair Mt is leading the charge
on that Wolfie are you coloring your
hair is that what's going on you know
Wolfie is a big star he can't have gray
hair oh you definitely yeah definitely
he's coloring his hair yeah why isother
to ask him he went so black it's
ridiculous how about this how about I
come in you have whatever expert you
want test my hair if I have any dye any
coloring in my hair at all or if I don't
mimed has to shave his head how about
that I just well what's going on are you
are you claiming you're not coloring
your hair you're not coloring your hair
no I I usually shave my head like every
two weeks and I just didn't do it so
last week Mt sees me on screen and my
hair's dark like I mean there's some
gray in there but I don't dye my hair
you know it's weird it looks like you
took shoe polish to your head yeah
exactly it is now know you shave your
head literally everyone in the meeting
was like what the [__] is going on with
Wolfie's hair I I would assume I would
assume it zoom in some way but there's
absolutely nothing in my hair I don't
use any dye in my shampoo actually does
do you dye your hair M no I I use an
anti-gray shampoo that's dye that's
exactly what that is not what is the
shampoo doing to your gray hair it
restores my natural
[Laughter]
color no but I don't go jet black that's
the the pot calling the kettle black
it's a totally different
mechanism